so many Tech reviewers are currently
talking about the iPhone finally coming
with a USB type-c port and how great
that's going to be how fast the data
transfers are going to be well I think a
lot of them are wrong and personally I
don't even want a USB type-c port on my
iPhone even though I use that Port all
the time I think if that happens it's
going to be a disappointment and it
might not happen at all and I have
multiple reasons to prove that now in
this video I'm going to share what I
think Apple will do and the crazy pads
that Apple has for Alternatives that
will be a lot better now all this
stemmed from the EU creating new law
that iPhones are going to have to ditch
the lightning and go to a standard that
is universal now Apple has been moving
to USB type-c across a lot of their
devices MacBooks first switched over in
2016 even for charging and then after
that we started switching on on the
iPads including the brand new 10
generation one now everybody thought
that that was great because finally the
lightning is gone from iPads but from
the very beginning I had a speculation
that Apple might not be telling us the
whole truth and I was right as we
started testing this new iPad I found
that the transfer speeds were horrific
on that iPad now you may be asking what
does this have to do with the future
iPhones well this is concrete proof
about what Apple can do and what they're
most likely going to do I will explain
this lightning port on the iPhone 14
series including the pro Max is also
still USB 2.0 and if Apple were to give
us fast speeds they would have done it
on this phone because not only does it
shoot Dolby Vision HDR prores files
which are huge it also shoots 4 48
megapixel Pro raw files that are
insanely detailed and about 75 megabytes
compared to about 3 megabytes in your
standard compressed 12 megapixel mode so
it would make sense to give it to this
phone but they didn't and to make
matters worse and to put salt in our
wounds the iPad Pro in 2015 with a
lightning Port ran at USB 3.0 speeds
compared to a 2022 almost 2023 phone
that actually needs the better transfer
with those large files and apple still
did not do that even with the a16 so
that means that if they do give us USB
type c it can still be the same super
slow USB 2.0 and that would be
incredibly frustrating now why would
they do that well there are a few
reasons when I looked into you how to
transfer these large files and to do the
conversions and what Apple wants to do
with it they blatantly advertise you to
just use airdrop to send files to your
Mac or to just upgrade your iCloud
storage so you can store these super
large files with the link directly to do
that that is why Apple limited this port
which in 2015 ran 10 times faster to
still have that super slow speed and I
don't think that would change next year
because for Apple they make money with
you buying their iCloud storage and with
you using airdrop because that means you
have to have a Mac which is why I am
stuck in the ecosystem because it is
very convenient so because of that I
think it's very naive to think that the
USB type-c port will give us fast data
transfers and I don't want a USB type-c
port that is limited now some people
want it because they want to have faster
charging and I would like that but once
again with this iPad even though it has
a USB type-c port the charging speed is
actually limited compared to the iPad
Air even though there's no reason to do
that they have the same batteries inside
there but Apple did limit that I want
something that is going to be an actual
Improvement instead of what we have now
which is severely limited including Max
save charging and I'll explain why now
that we're talking about wireless
charging this Halo lock mini kickstand
Wireless power bank from our sponsor ESR
has really impressed me because compared
to the Apple Mac say power bank it was
able to give me a lot more charge and
the charge is faster than anchors while
having the strongest magnets it has that
kickstand which apples doesn't and the
charging port is on the side so you can
use it as a desk charging station and
the battery pack doesn't stick below the
6.1 inch iPhones like the anchor does
also unlike apples you can turn off
wireless charging if you you don't want
it to charge which is great when you're
using it as a stand with that ESR it's
really great reviews and it's actually
quite a bit less expensive compared to
the other options we also have a 10 000
milliamp hour model if you're trying to
get the highest capacity so check out
the link in the description to pick up
one of these ESR haloc wireless chargers
for a killer price and start wireless
charging today now personally I have
been wireless charging my iPhone almost
exclusively ever since magsafe came out
with the iPhone 12. I am a huge fan of
magsafe it is so convenient I've made
many videos covering the top accessories
including comparisons with different
Wireless power Banks but some people say
well you still have to have a data
connection but you guys may be wrong
that could all change very soon now
there are two things that really
frustrate me about macsafe and one is
the fact that Apple locks out third
parties from having that 15 in what
capability but with that even though the
max 8 Puck is rated at 15 watts that
doesn't last long after that first
initial burst it actually drops down to
6 Watts which is lower than what ESR
offers on theirs or other companies
offer so they're not maximizing it and
other companies they're not allowed to
do that unless you're paying apple and
you're limiting it to what they want
personally I want faster charging
similar to what OnePlus has done where
they have 50 watt Chargers that charge
way faster than lightning does with the
iPhone more than what Apple allow you
with USB type c now we don't need to
have 50 Watts but that is just proof the
Apple can do that with macsafe on the
iPhone and of course we had leaks that
they want to make it faster but they
have not made a change even with the
iPhone 14. now another thing that many
Tech reviewers did not talk about is
that this EU law only goes into to
effect at the end of 2024 not next year
with the iPhone 15 and another is the
Apple has wanted to have a portless
iPhone for a long time and now we know
that the iPhone 15 is going to have
solid state buttons on the side instead
of having actual ones which is great for
a few different reasons that's just like
the home button that we had on the
previous iPhones and like the trackpad
that doesn't actually click down and
another thing that you have to consider
is that this is just a law for the EU
Apple doesn't have to do worldwide and
if you think that Apple would do it
worldwide if they do it at all we'll
take a look at the SIM card slot or the
lack of it in the North American models
of the iPhone and the rest of the world
they still have it but for us we don't
so Apple could easily do that with a USB
type-c port but personally I think they
wouldn't include it at all and there's a
very legitimate reason for this because
another interesting point is that Apple
only has to put in a USB type-c port if
they have a wired connection if they
don't have a wired connection they don't
have to use those rules which also means
that Apple could do another method of
physical connection which would be a
SMART connector like Port which they do
have patents for that allows it to
magnetically attach and align now what I
think is better in that we do have proof
on is the ability to have magsafe
wireless charging not only be able to
wirelessly charge but pass through data
and yes Apple does have a patent on that
as well you can have mac safe charging
which is fast and then use Optical light
transfer to pass through data for the
times that you actually need to have a
physical connection for example recovery
of your phone or if you want to back it
up then things like that now most people
nowadays only use the lightning to
charge everything's done through iCloud
and that's what Apple would prefer and
of course they make more money that way
with iCloud backup now if you think
that's weird to use that for data that
might be slow well this port is
incredibly slow the iPad 10 sport is
incredibly slow and if you think about
it fiber optic cable for gigabit it is
insanely fast and there was a study done
showing that wireless fiber optic light
transfer reaches 42 gigabit per second
that is like about 90 times faster than
this lightning port and that is actually
faster than Thunderbolt 4 data transfer
it is absolutely insane so not only is
Apple hold a patent to this it works
incredibly well and they could easily do
that now personally I would also really
like a focus on faster airdrop airdrop
is great but it's actually not that fast
if you're transferring photos as that's
what I found when I was trying to send
these huge raw files from my iPhone to
my computer and with that what gives me
proof that Apple doesn't want to add USB
type-c to their iPhone and they'd rather
bypass the eu's regulations is the fact
that their brand new airpods Pro 2
instead of switching to USB type c like
they have on other devices even on beat
stuff they did on this iPad they are
sticking with a lightning connector and
these things usually only get updated
every three years they are still doing
this and that just shows me that they
would rather just stick it to the EU use
another method that you can license and
make more money on and we know they've
wanted a portless iPhone they like
making money and they like having
control and not having other people tell
them what to do so you guys let me know
your thoughts are you excited about usb
type-c coming does the speeds matter or
Apple's way of controlling stuff go
ahead and click that subscribe button
above if you guys want to see more
videos check check out one of those
great ones right over there this Max and
I'll see you in the next one
[Music]